انا بكون مشاهدينا اذا مستمرون معكم في
هذه التغطيه بعد نحو 24 ساعه على وقوع
الزلزال العنيف الذي هز جنوب شرق تركيا
وشمال سوريا فجر الاثنين وتبعه زلزال اخر
صباح اليوم ارتفعت حصيله القتلى لتبلغ نحو
ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمئه شخص في تركيا الحصيله غير
النهائيه بلغت
2370 قتيل وفق الهيئه التركيه لاداره
الكوارث واعلنت اصابه
14,483 شخص تم انقاذ سبعه الاف وثمانمائه
واربعين شخصا حتى الان في سوريا بلغ عدد
الضحايا اجمالي عدد الضحايا حتى الان نحو
بينهم
771 شخص في مناطق سيطره النظام بينما توفي
وثلاث مئه وسبعمائه وثلاثين في مناطق
المعارضه حسب ما افادت الخوذ البيضاء طبعا
هذه الحصيله مرشحه للارتفاع في ظل وجود
عدد كبير من المحاصرين في تركيا وفي سوريا
وبالطبع هناك الاف العائلات تبيت في
العراق على كل حال ينضم الينا من تركيا
زيدان زنكلونا على اخر
التطورات والى اين وصلت جهود البحث عن
ناجين
الحصيله كما ذكرت
2379 هي
حصيله الضحايا وايضا
1483 هي حصيله
المصابين وحصيله من ثم انقاذهم تجاوز
تجاوزت 7800 لكن ما تسعى اليه تركيا الان
هو زياده عدد الفرق الفرق الانقاذ التي
تقوم بمهام البحث عن الناجين تحت الانقاض
وايضا ازاله الكتل الخرسانيه الناجمه عن
انهيارات المباني بالتالي الاخبار
الايجابيه في هذا الطلب ما صرح به مدير
افاد او هيئه الطاقه والكوارث التركيه عن
انضمام اكثر من
51 الف شخص الى هذه الى كوادر افاد
للمساهمه في عمليات
الانقاذ وايضا البحث عن ناجين ايضا
[موسيقى]
المساعدات التي بدات تصل تباعا من خارج
تركيا وايضا المساعدات القادمه من بقيه
الولايات التركيه الى المناطق من كوبا
طبعا مما شاهدناه ايضا بعض المخيمات التي
انشاتها افاد او هيئه الطوارئ والتوازن
التركيه في بعض المناطق المنكوبه بحسب
نائب الرئيس التركي ايضا
فؤاد قبل قليل فان اكثر من 52 الف شخص تم
استيعابهم في مراكز الايواء في الولايات
العشر لكن كما نعلم هو هذا العدد قليل
نوعا مقارنه بعدد سكان هذه المناطق وعدد
الاشخاص الذين نزلوا الى الشوارع ولا
يستطيعون الان العوده الى منازلهم اما
باضرار حدثت في المنزل
ومن تشققات او تصدعات في بعض الجدران او
ربما في البناء نفسه او خوفا مخافه من
الهزات الاعتداديه اكثر ما تحذر منه
السلطات التركيه
للمواطنين الاتراك في تلك المناطق من
ضروره الابتعاد عن المساكن او المنازل
اثناء
تجنبا للهزات الارتداديه التي يمكن ان
تشكل او تكون عاملا تدميريا اكثر من
الزلزال نفسي نفسه كما قال في وقت سابق من
هذا اليوم تحدثت عن عدد كبير من النقاط
دعني ابدا معك بنقطه فرق الاغاثه هناك
الكثير من الدول التي اعلنت انها سترسل
فرق انقاذ وكلاب مدربه للبحث عن ناجين هل
وصلت طلائع هذه الفرق وانتشرت في اماكن
الزلزال ام انه يتم الاعتماد الان على
الفرق المحليه وهل هناك فرق كافيه تعمل في
الولايات العشر التي طالها الزلزال
عند عصر هذا اليوم عندما صرح الرئيس
التركي بان 9000 شخص يعملون
كفرق انقاذ وهم جميعهم من المواطنين
الاتراك وايضا مدربين بشكل جيد كانت
الاعمال بان يزداد هذا العدد حتى يستطيع
هؤلاء ان يلبوا او ان يغطوا كل المناطق
المنكوبه نتحدث عن مناطق شاسعه جدا
ابراهيم في جنوب تركيا
انضم الى هؤلاء
3500 من عناصر الجيش التركي لكن مع الحديث
عن
انضمام او تاكيد مدير افاد انضمام اكثر من
51 الف يعني الامور بدات تاخذ منحه ايجابي
اكثر المعنويات بدات ترتفع نعمان ما ومع
وصول الطلائع الاولى او وصول اولى الفرق
الانقاذ وصلح حوالي 370 شخصا من اذربيجان
واذربيجان كانت اول دوله اعلنت صباح هذا
اليوم في وقت مبكر او صباحها على اعتبار
اننا دخلنا في يوم الثلاثاء اعلنت بصراحه
الاثنين انها سترسل فرق انقاذ بالفعل فرق
الالقاب التي وصلت من اذربيجان كانت اولى
فرق الانقاذ التي وصلت الى تركيا مساء
الاثنين وبالتالي تنتظر تركيا وصول فرق
بالفعل بعض الاطلاق قد غادرت البلدان من
الدول الاوروبيه تنتظر تركيا الوصول فرق
اضافيه من اسبانيا
سنناقش هذا الموضوع مع مراسلينا في اوروبا
والولايات المتحده لكن دعنا نتحدث عن نقطه
المحاصرين هل هناك اي احصائيات لعدد
المحاصرين
وهل تم الابلاغ عن ارقام محدده وكيف يتم
التعامل مع الاشخاص الموجودين الان في
العراء خصوصا ان الهزات الارتداديه تمنعهم
من العوده الى منازلهم كما تحدثت ومراكز
لواء لا تستطيع ان تستوعبهم في ظل هذا
العدد الكبير وايضا الدرجات الحراره
المخفضه في جنوب شرق تركيا
نعم ابراهيم الان التحدي الاكبر لدى
السلطات التركيه وطواقم على الانقاذ هو
زياده اولا عدد الطواقم الانقاذ لتغطيه
مساحات اوسع من المناطق المتضرره بالتالي
هي معادله
بسيطه زياده زياده عدد متطوعين بشكل اكبر
او زياده طواقم انقاذ يشكل اكبر يعني وصول
اسرع لكل المناطق المتضرره وبالتالي
الوصول الى كل المحاصرين او العالقين تحت
الانقاض طبعا الفرق الانقاذ مدربه بشكل
جيد للتعامل مع هذه الموضوع الاليات يتم
استخدامها ولكن هناك مشكله احيانا تؤخر
الوصول او تؤخر وصول احيانا الاليات وهو
وهي الاثار الدمار التي خلفها الزلزال في
الطرق التي واصله بين الولايات الطرق
الرئيسيه او حتى الطرق الفرعيه ايضا بعض
الطرق الرئيسيه تشهد ازدحام كبير من
الاشخاص او من السكان المحليين الذين
يريدون مغادره المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
وهذا احيانا يعيق
وصول طواقم الانقاذ وسيارات الاسعاف
والتواطن الطبيه لذلك الموضوع
نوعا ما يحد او هذه العوامل تحد من قدره
الطلاق الانقاذ على
انجاز العمل بشكل اسرع اضف الى ذلك
ابراهيم عامل الطقس السيء جدا جدا موجه
الموجه الهوائيه البارده وهطول الثلوج
الكثيفه التي هطرت في عديد المدن
والتحذيرات التي سبقت الزلزال من موضوع
العواصف الثلجيه ودوره توخي الحدث هذه
العوامل المناخيه ايضا تؤثر سلبا بما
يتعلق
الهائمين على وجوههم اذا استخدمنا هذه هذا
هذه الكلمه وهذا المصطلح ابراهيم لا شك ان
حاله القلق الشديد والتوتر والخوف والرعب
الذي عاشه سكان الولايات العشر اثرت سلبا
وخصوصا يعني في موضوع سريان اشاعات عديده
سواء عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي او عبر
تناقل هذه الاحاديث بشكل فردي عن احتماليه
وقوع زلازل
ارتداديه نعم يعني هل هناك طيب جهه حكوميه
تقيم ما اذا كان هذا المبنى او ذاك صالحا
للسكن من عدم وخصوصا انه يعني الاشخاص
يعني لا يستطيعون الحكم اذا كان هناك
تصدعات قد تهدد مبنى ما من السقوط من
يتحكم في هذه القضيه تحديدا
نعم هذه هذا الموضوع تحديدا ابراهيم لم
تبدا به حتى الان الفرقه المختصه مختصه او
اذا بدا فهو على اطار ضيق الاولويه الان
استثمار كل الطاقات والكوادر البشريه في
اخراج المحاصرين والعالقين بما بعد عندما
تتم توسيع او زياده عن الطواقم سيتم
تلقائيا الى اين يلجا هؤلاء يعني هل وفرت
الحكومه التركيه اماكن لتواجدهم من خلال
يعني المباني الحكوميه الملاعب المدارس
وهل هي يعني مؤهله لاستقبالهم
ويمكن ان تحتمل ايها ارتداديه قد تحدث
نعم لا شك ان
الاول لجميع السكان هو المدارس
الجامعات السكن الجامعي في الجامعات ايضا
الصلاه الرياضيه والمراكز الثقافيه كل هذه
النشاطات اوقاتها تركيا لاستيعاب
الولايات او المشاهدين لكن رغم كل
الازدحام الذي تشهده هذه المركز وحتى دور
العباده ايضا المساجد
والمراكز الاوقاف او كل المراكز التابعه
رغم كل هذا هناك ازدحام كبير وهناك ضغط
على هذا المراكز وهناك ايضا
اشخاص كثر يرفضون البقاء هناك خوفا من
الهزات الاعتداريه كما ذكرت ابراهيم حاله
الخوف والهلع بشكل كبير بين السكان لذلك
كثر من لا يريد ان يبقى ضمن بناء حتى لو
كان مؤمن ومجهز لكل
وسائل الامان يريد ان يبقى في العراء في
الحدائق العامه في اماكن مكشوفه في اماكن
بعيده عن الابنيه
والسكن وبالتالي هناك اشخاص كثر مع الاسف
سياخذون ليلتهم في درجات حراره تحت ما دون
الصفر في غازي عنتاب خمس درجات تحت الصفر
وايضا في كهرمان مرعش الحراره اقل ذلك
بكثير هذه الظروف صراحه يعني سيئه خصوصا
ممن يمتلكون اطفال او كبار
تفضل تفضل البقاء مع ساعود لك زيدان كنت
معنا من اسطنبول شكرا لك على كل هذه
الاحاطه حتى الساعه تفضل البقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وزعت قلبي ابوي
[موسيقى]
ذكرنا اكلينا بس الله هيك نحن نايمين
رب العالمين هذا هون
[موسيقى]
اذا تابعنا هذه الصور من المدن التي تضررت
في شمال سوريا جراء هذا الزلزال والان حسب
الاخبار العاجله مسؤول اممي تضرر الطرق
والثلوج ونقص المحروقات عوامل تعيق عمليات
الانقاذ في سوريا انضم الينا على كل حال
من القاهره مدير مرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك استاذ
رامي لو طلعنا على سير عمليات الانقاذ
سواء في مناطق المعارضه او سيطره النظام
نعم مساء الخير طبعا اعتقد بان عمليات
الانقاذ توقفت بشكل شبه كامل الان نتيجه
عدم وجود امكانيات لاستمرار الطرق الانقاذ
بعمليه انتشال من هم تحت انقاذ هذه
المباني نقول بان هناك مئات الاسر لا تزال
تحت انقاذ المباني المهمه التي يعني سقطت
على رؤوسهم والهرس الارتجاجيه زادت
الكارثه بانهيار مزيد من يعني من كان
امكان الامكانيه لانقاذهم سقطت عليهم ايضا
هذه المباني تحدث نحن يعني عن اعداد كبيره
من المفقودين نتحدث عن الان الجو بارد
بشكل كبير جدا نحن في الدفء الان وهم الان
تحت الانقاذ اذا ما كانوا على قيد الحياه
هل سيبقون على قيد الحياه ام سيطارقون
الحياه نتيجه هذا الجو البارد وهم في تحت
هذا الركام الذي لا نعلم ما هو مصيرهم هل
الارض كم عدد الاطفال كم عدد النساء كم
عدد الرجال والشيوخ يعني وضع كارثي
وماساوي منذ صباح نقول وضع كارثه واساوي
منذ الصباح نقول بان العدد مرشح للارتفاع
كنا نرفع العدد عشرات واذا به يرتفع
بالمئات تتحدث عن حتى اللحظه عن
1417 على الاقل حقيقه الامر هؤلاء الذين
توفوا
بنتيجه هذا الزلزال الكارثي الذي ضرب
الاراضي التركيه يعني امتد الى داخل
الاراضي السوريه ولكن اقول لك بداخل
الاراضي السوريه هو اص الاراضي التركيه
داخل تركيا يوجد فرق انقاذ في الاراضي
السوريه لا يوجد امكانيه امكانيات سواء
لدى النظام او لدى المعارضه من انقاذ يعني
المزيد من ابناء السوريين العراقيين تحت
الانقاذ
هل نقص المعادات نقص الكوادر فرق الانقاذ
بشكل قطعي بشكل قطعي هناك معدات هناك يعني
اقول لك حتى مناطق النظام لا يوجد فيها
هناك
لقب نق
[موسيقى]
الشمالي اي ان الخسائر الى الان لم تحصى
سواء لدى النظام سواء لدى
يعني ليست نهائيا
رامي من يقوم بجهود الانقاذ ومساعده الناس
خصوصا اولئك الموجودين يعني او الموجودون
في العراء في ظل انخفاض درجات الحراره وهل
تم ايصال بعض المساعدات من تركيا الى
مناطق المعارضه عبر الحدود
بعض المساعدات وصلت فعلا ولكن هل
المساعدات التي وصلت تكفي هل هؤلاء الذين
هم في العراء اين سيباتون الان هل يوجد
خيم تاوي هؤلاء حقيقه الامر هل يوجد منازل
امنه تاوي هؤلاء وحتى المدنيين السوريين
الذين لن تتهدم منازلهم بل تصدعتهم يفضلون
المبيت في العراء على ان يباتوا في هذه
المنازل المتصدعه خوفا من هزات ارتداديه
تؤدي لسقوط المنازل على رؤوس من هم فيها
الاليه لذلك اقول بان المخاوفيه كبيره جدا
من الحدود السوريه العراقيه التركيه في
اقصى شباب شرق سوريا وصولا الى الساحل
السوري كل هذه المناطق يوجد فيها حالات
خوف ورعب الكثير من الذين شعروا بالهزه
الارضيه اتصلوا باقاربهم في الخارج وقالوا
نحن نودعكم نحن نفارق الحياه كان هناك
حاله من الرعب حقيقه الامر حاله من الرعب
كبيره جدا عمت التراب السوري وتحديدا
المناطق التي تصدعت فيها المنازل حلب سنه
اكبر
السوريه حجم الكارثه فيها هناك تقديرات
ربما لاعداد الاشخاص المحاصرين خصوصا انه
البعض يقول بانه الى الان لا توجد ارقام
حكوميه شفافه يمكن من خلالها معرفه حقيقه
الوضع على الارض
من المصادر الطبيه داخل المشافي يعني حتى
ارقام يعني هناك تضارب في الارقام ما بين
الجهات العامله في المعارضه ومناطق النظام
النظام يتحدث عن انه بامكانه صباحا قال
بانه بامكانه ان يساعد الذين هم تضرروا
نتيجه الزلزال واذا به لاحقا يناشط الدول
العربيه صراحه ناشدنا النظام قال بانه
ارسل فرق طبيا من دمشق ودرعا ومناطق اخرى
الى حلب يعني وتاخرت الفرق الطبيه وحتى لو
وصلت الفرق الطبيه هل يوجد لديهم امكانيات
لمساعده كل هذه الاعداد الكبيره من الذين
يصيب ونتيجه هذا الزلزال لم يكن لديهم
امكانيات حقيقه الامر اعتقد بان هناك
اعداد كبيره من العارفين تحت الانقاذ هناك
شاهدنا مباني تسقط بالصوت والصوره في
احياء حلب بعد الزلزال نتيجه الهزات
الاقتصاديه شاهدنا صوره واحده مقطع مصور
واحد بينما لا لم نشاهد عشرات المباني
الاخرى التي هوت دون ان نشاهدها طيب هل
صدر موقف عن النظام امكانيات السماح بمرور
مساعدات الى المنظمات الانسانيه وان تتولى
هي تقديمها للمواطنين في اماكن سيطرته يا
سيدي بان النظام هو مساهم اساسي باستمرار
سقوط ضحايا هؤلاء السوريين الان لا
يحتاجون الى موقف سياسي يحتاجون الى حل
انساني يمنع سقوط المزيد من الضحايا في
المشافي سقوط المزيد او محاوله انقاذ من
هم الان تحت انقاذ المباني لذلك اقول بان
يجب ان نبعد السياسه الان ولا تم فقط
بالشق الانساني سواء في منظر او في مناطق
المعارضه او في مناطق السيطره التركيه انت
تفضل بقى معي فقط دعنا نشير انه في مقابله
مع العربيه قال المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا حسام شرقاوي
قال ان الوضع الامني في سوريا يعيق عمليه
وصول المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ الى المناطق
المتضرره
قامت والطائرات تتحرك والقافله تتحرك خاصه
من الدول المجاوره
وعلى خلال ساعات الدعم وصل خاصه من الدول
المجاوره
توصيل الدعم داخل سوريا طبعا له في صعوبات
انه نوصل داخل سوريا كون المطار وضعه
ماساوي
ونوصل الدعم للمناطق المنكوبه خاصه انه
العاصفه الثلجيه اللي صار لها كذا يوم
الان مستمره
تعيق
التوصيل الدعم وبرضو الوضع الامني
عندما يتحدث استاذ رامي عن الوضع الامني
انه يعيق ايصال المساعدات ما المقصود بهذه
الجزئيه تحديدا
لديهم مخاوف في النهايه الفرق الاجنبيه
تخاف من الاستهدافات داخل سوريا
يكون هناك تفجيرات داخل سوريا هم يعني
تهمهم انسانيين نعم ولكن تهمهم في النهايه
حياتهم الشخصيه يعني في بلد لا تعتقد ان
فيه حقيقه الامر نعلم ما يوجد في البلد
نعلم الحواجز الامنيه نعلم النقاط الامنيه
نعلم بيئات الحواجز لعناصر ان الفرقه
الرابعه لذلك اقول بان الوضع هو ليس امن
ولكن تستطيع الفرق الطبيه
الصليب احمر الهبوط في مطار دمشق الدولي
في مطار حلب الدوله مثل ما كانت تهبط
شاحنات السلاح الايرانيه يعني
الطائرات السلاح الايرانيه فلتهبط طائرات
الاغاثه من قبل المجتمع الدولي من قبل
الامم المتحده من قبل من يريد ان يصل يصل
الى مستحقيها داخل الاراضي السوريه شكرا
جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات التي قدمتها
لنا مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن كنت معنا مباشره من
القاهره
يؤكد استعداد منظمه الامم المتحده لدعم
جهود الاستجابه الطارئه بعيدا وجهت فريقي
للتنسيق مع تركيا وتوفير المساعدات
اللازمه
بوتين مستعدون للمساعده في القضاء على
تداعيات الكارثه
فرنسا مستعده لتوفير مساعده عاجله للسكان
في تركيا وسوريا اسرائيل تعرض ارسال فرق
بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى تركيا وسوريا
المانيا تعهدت بتقديم مساعدات شامله
لضحايا الزلزال عبر كل الوسائل المتاحه
ايطاليا بدات بالفعل في تجهيز فرق الانقاذ
التي ستسافر الى تركيا
بكين تعلن استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات
انسانيه عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا
عبرت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن خشيتها من
ان ترتفع حصيله ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا
الى ثمانيه اضعاف الحصيله المسجله الان في
الاثناء قال رئيس برنامج الغذاء العالمي
ديفيد بيزلي ان فرق الطوارئ التابعه
للبرنامج الساعات لتقديم المساعده اذا
اقتضت الضروره بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا اقدم بزلي عبر حسابه على موقع
تويتر تعازيه لعائلات ضحايا الزلزال
اعلنت سلطات الرومانيه ارسال الوحدات
انقاذ الى تركيا للمساعده في عمليات
الاغاثه الجراء تداعيات الزلزال وتتضمن
الفرق تلك عشرات من المختصين بالانقاذ وعد
عددا من الكلاب المدربه على البحث تحت
الانقاض
اكدت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان فرنسا
سترسل 17 عنصرا من فرق الانقاذ وخمسه
وستين عنصرا من فرق الاطفاء لتركيا
بالاضافه الى افراد من مركز الازمات
والدعم وذلك استجابه لطلب الدعم الدولي
الذي قدمته تركيا
والمزيد متابعه ينضم الينا من باريس مراسل
العربيه حسين قنيبر اهلا بك يا حسين حسين
هل اتضحت الاليه ونوعيه المساعدات وتوقيت
وصولها من باريس الى انقره
نعم في الواقع ابراهيم منذ ان اعلن الرئيس
الفرنسي صباحا ان الصور المروعه التي
تصلنا من تركيا وسوريا غير مسبوقه ونحن
على استعداد لتقديم مساعدات عاجله الى
السكان سارعت الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى
الاعلان عن اطلاق عمليه
الحمايه المدنيه وسترسل فرنسا في اطار هذه
العمليه الى تركيا
واحدا وسبعين عنصرا من فرق الانقاذ وخمسه
وستين عنصرا من فرق الاطفاء وافرادا من
مركز الازمات والدعم التابع لوزاره
الخارجيه هؤلاء سيصلون خلال ساعات وذلك
استجابه لطلب الدعم الدولي الذي عبرت عنه
تركيا كما جاء في بيان الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الذي اوضح ايضا انه سيصار الى ارسال
مفرزتين تابعتين لوزاره الداخليه
عن فرقته العامله على الارض فقد شمل
الدمار في تركيا في المناطق التي تعمل
فيها هذه المنظمات الانسانيه الفرنسيه شمل
مدن يسكنها 12 مليون شخص من بين هؤلاء
ايضا مليونير لاجئ سوري ابرز هذه المدن
غازي عنتاب اضنه اديمان ديار بكر هاتاي
كلس
وملاتيا اخيرا اضاف هذا البيان الفرنسي
بيان مواطنات الانسانيه انه في سوريا تركز
الدمار على حلب وادلب والمناطق المحيطه
بهما ولمواجهه تداعيات هذه الكارثه التي
ادت الى تدمير الاف المباني ومن ضمنها
مستشفيات يجب الاسراع في مساعده ابناء هذه
المناطق الواقعه على مساحه تبلغ 400 كيلو
متر على جانبي الحدود في جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا ابراهيم افهم من كلامك بان هذه
منظمات الانسانيه التحالف هذه المنظمات
ابدت استعدادها لمساعده ايضا ضحايا هذا
الزلزال في سوريا ايضا لكن ماذا عن موقف
باريس من
مساعده الضحايا في سوريا هل اتضح موقف
الحكومه الفرنسيه من هذا الامر
نعم في الوا
قع لعدم وجود علاقات بين الحكومتين
السوريه والتركيه فان الارجح ان عفوا بين
الحكومتين الفرنسيه والسوريه فان الارجح
ان تمر المساعدات الى سوريا عبر المنظمات
الانسانيه التي ذكرتها والتي اعلنت من
خلال بيان لتحالفها ان هذه المنظمات تقوم
حاليا بتقييم الحاجات في المناطق المنكوبه
جميعا لم تحدد ما اذا كان ذلك في تركيا او
سوريا بل قالت انها تقيم الحاجات في
المناطق المنكوبه جميعا وتنظم المرحله
الاولى من المساعدات بالتنسيق مع السلطات
المحليه تخشى هذه المنظمات ان يرتفع ان
ترتفع حصيله الضحايا بشكل كبير نظرا ليس
فقط الى العدد الكبير من الضحايا الذين ما
يزلون تحت الانقاض بل نظرا ايضا لتشرد
الاف الاشخاص
قارهم الى ماوى والى الغذاء والعنايه
الطبيه المنظمات الاعضاء في التحالف تقوم
حاليا بتقييم الحاجات في المناطق المنكوبه
كما ذكرت تركز على تقديم اسعافات اوليه
والدعم النفسي وتوزيع المواد الغذائيه
الضروريه وكذلك المواد الطبيه شكرا جزيلا
لك
مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من باريس
ونعرض لكم مشاهدينا الان صور هذه الفرق
الفرنسيه اذا هؤلاء هم فرق الدعم التي
اعلنت وزيره خارجيه الفرنسيه
كاترين كولونا انها
سيتم ارسالها
17 عنصر من فرق الانقاذ 65 عنصر من فرق
الاطفاء بالاضافه الى افراد ايضا من مركز
الازمات والدعم استجابه لطلب الدعم الدولي
الذي قدمته تركيا كما افادنا مراسل
العربيه حسين قنيبل اذا بدات هذه الفرق
بالتوجه الى تركيا في سباق مع الزمن
لانقاذ المحاصرين تحت انقاض مئات المباني
التي سقطت في جنوب شرق تركيا
اذا خلال زيارته مدينه ملطيه شرق تركيا
وهي احدى المدن التي تضررت او التي تضررت
بشده من الزلزال اعلن وزير التعليم التركي
محمود اوزر عن اغلاق جميع المدارس في
البلاد حتى الثالث عشر من الشهر الجاري
اخذا بعين الاعتبار المناخ والظروف
الحاليه في جميع انحاء تركيا ومن اجل
مواصله الاعمال في مناطق الزلزال بشكل
اكثر هدوءا ليس فقط في مناطق الزلزال بل
في جميع انحاء البلاد نعلن عن عطله في
جميع مدارس تركيا حتى الثالث عشر من
فبراير
لا يمكن التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل حدوثه لاجل
ذلك يصعب تفادي تداعياته الخطره والتي
تكون احيانا مدمره حسب قوته بمقياس ريختر
لنلقي مع النظره عامه حول كيفيه حصول
الزلزال يعرف الزلزال بانه اهتزاز ارضي
مفاجئ ينتج عن الحركه المستمره للصفائح
التكتونيه والتي تتسبب بتراكم الضغط على
طبقات الصخور على جانبي الصدوق الواقعه
بين الصفائح ما يؤدي الى تكسر الكتل
الصخريه وانزلاقها فوق بعضها البعض
بالتالي اطلاق الطاقه المخزنه في القشره
الارضيه في حركه مفاجئه ينتج عنها موجات
تحمل طاقه زلزاليه تنتشر عبر صخور الارض
لتصل الى السطح ما يتسبب بحدوث الاهتزازات
الزلزاليه تتعدد الاسباب او عفوا تتعدد
الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصوله لتشمل الزلازل
التكتونيه التي تعد الاكثر شيوعا هنا يحدث
انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع المحيط لينقسم
الى عدد من الاجزاء او الصفائح الصلبه
التي تتراوح سمكتها بين 100 و150 كيلو متر
لتتحرك بعدها حركه مستمره فوق طبقه الغلاف
الموري التي تقع تحت القشر الارضيه هناك
ايضا الزلزال البركاني الذي يحدث بسبب
البراكين النشطه لكن ليس بقوه الزلزال
التكتوني غالبا ما تحدث هذه الزلازل
بالقرب من سطح الارض لذلك يتم الشعور بها
فقط بالقرب من نقطه منشا الزلزال يعقب
حدوث الزلزال العديد من الاحداث والاثار
التي قد تكون مدمره يمكن ان تتخذ اشكال
متعدده من بينها الانهيارات الفيضانات
الحرائق وسيل التربه وتسونامي واليكم
مشاهدينا بعض النصائح عند وقوع الزلازل
وبعدها وفق الخبره
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي
اوكتاي يلمس اهلا بك يا استاذ قبل ان
نتحدث عن موضوع الزلازل
ومخاوف الناس في تركيا من الهزات
الارتداديه هل لديكم اي تحديث للمعلومات
حول اخر ما وصلت اليه جهود الانقاذ وايضا
اعداد
الذين توفوا المحاصرين اذا كانت موجوده
لديكم
تحيه طيبه مساء الخير نعم يعني
المعلومات الجديده يعني كما ذكرتم لم تاتي
معلومه جديده
المسؤولون من حين الى حين
يعلن يعلنون عن المعلومات الجديده
كعدت الضحايا الى الان الرقم
2379 قتيل
و14,483 جريح لم يتغير
للاسف هذا العدد يعني من الواضح انه مرشح
للتزايد نظرا
بعدم وصول فرق الانقاذ الى حتى الى بعض
المباني المنهاره او حتى استمرار
العمليه البحث والانقاذ
يعني نحن نتحدث عن مناطق واسعه جدا هذا
نحن لا نتحدث عن الزلزال واحد في الحقيقه
او من اقوى الزلزالات في المسجله في
التاريخ الحديث خاصه في تركيا
وقع
زلزالان زلزال الاول وبعده بساعات الزلزال
الثاني تقريبا بنفس القوه الزلزال الاول
كان بقوه 7.7
المساله الثانيه سبعه فاصله سته ما لم
يدمر من المباني دمرت في الزلزال الثاني
طبعا
بالاضافه الى زلزالات الارتباطيه مستمره
يعني كرقم حتى الان
هناك حديث عن اكثر من
150 حوالي 150 وحتى بعض المصادر يعني رصدت
نحو 200 هزه ارتداديه في عقاب الزلزلين
الكبيرين
سؤال يتحدث عن ان فرق الانقاذ لم تصل الى
كل المناطق التي طالها الدمار منظمه الصحه
العالميه توقعت ان يكون عدد الضحايا
ثمانيه اضعاف الاعداد الاوليه التي يتم
الاعلان عنها هذا رقم كبير نتمنى ان لا
يكون صحيح لكن هل انت يعني تخشى من ان
يرتفع الرقم ليتجاوز الرقم المعلن الان
باضعاف ليصل الى ثمانيه اضعاف
للاسف يعني هذا صحيح
اتوقع للاسف تجاوز الارقام يعني اضعاف
ما اعلن حتى الان نحن لا نتحرك كما قلت
يعني هناك زلزالان كبيران
ونتحدث عن منطقه
واسعه جدا
شم شمل هذا الزلزال او هذا
اكثر من عشر
محافظات تركيه
تعيش في هذه المناطق حوالي 15 مليون
نسمه
وتم هدم حتى الان
كارقام رسميه حوالي 7000 مبنى مدمر
بالكامل
وكما قلت ان والبحث
وعمليه الانقاذ مستمره
في زلزال مرمره في عام 99 من القرن الماضي
قبل
14 سنه
راحت راحه ضحيه هذا زلزال حوالي 18 الف
شخص انتم تتوقعون ان يكون حصيله هذا
الزلزال اكبر اسمح لي فقط هناك كانت
توقعات بان يتمنى لا نتمنى ولكن
ما نشاهده والارقام والواقع ربما
وحتى منظمه الصحه العالميه تشير الى هذا
الامر لا نتمنى بالفعل نتمنى السلامه
للجميع وللمحاصرين لكن السؤال انه تركيا
منطقه زلازل تعودت ان تضربها الزلازل كان
هناك توقعات بان يضرب الزلزال القادم
اسطنبول لكن هل كان هناك استعدادات في هذه
المنطقه جنوب شرق تركيا لهكذا زلزال واليه
مدى تركيا تتمتع يعني او تمتلك ما يكفي من
الامكانات والخبرات
والاليات
لمواجهه كارثه بهذا الحجم
نعم السؤال الوجه جدا هناك نقطه مهمه اولا
تركيا بعد
زلزال
مرمره عام 99 من القرن الماضي حقيقه تحركت
استدركت انها بلد يعني تقع في جغرافيا
الزلزالات وهناك خطوط رئيسيه خط الاناضول
التي
يمر من شرق اناضول حتى الى مرمره الى
اسطنبول وهذا قطر رئيسي وهناك خط اخر من
يمر كذلك من شرق تركيا الى جنوب تركيا حتى
الى الحدود السوريه وهما خطان الرئيسان
للزيزان
وبدا الاستعدادات
لذلك
تم هناك
مشروع حكومي لتحديث المباني تقديم تساؤلات
لاصحاب المباني الذين يحدثون يجددون
مبانئهم وتم تاسيس هيئه اداره الكوارث
التي تدير الان تشرف على الان على عمليه
البحث والانقاذ في هذا الزلزال وكذلك بدات
التوعيه
يعني
عمل
التوعيه
لكن رغم كل هذه الجهود هناك مباني قديمه
وتحطيس المباني تم سيد الكريم تم تحديث
المباني الحكوميه الى حد كبير من المدارس
الى المشافي وما الى ذلك خاصه تركيز كان
في منطقه مرمره بحيث ان اكثر المناطق
اكتظاظا للسكان والصناعه وما الى ذلك
يعني هناك
تطور وتقدم بهذا الخصوص ولكن بنفس الوقت
كذلك هذه المنطقه يعني كان من المعروف جدا
انها كذلك
يعني تقع في الجغرافيا الزلازل وهناك خط
وحصل زلازل سابقه في مدينه وان في مدينه
العزيز وما الى ذلك ولكن على ما يبدو ومن
الواضح جدا ان التحضيرات في هذه المنطقه
لم تكون
في المستوى المطلوب كتحديث البنيه التحتيه
تحديث المباني تبيعيه المواطنين الاشراف
يعني لا توجد مشاكل في القوانين تم تحديث
قيود حساسه جدا على بناء وانشاء المباني
ولكن كانت هناك مشاكل في المراقبه نعم نعم
ساعود لاستكمال الحديث معك لكن اسمح لي ان
اتابع هذه التغطيه من الولايات المتحده
حيث اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال
مكالمه هاتفيه اجراها مع نظيره التركيه
رجب طيب اردوغان جاهزيه بلاده لتوفير اي
مساعده تحتاجها تركيا للاستجابه لكارثه
الزلزال المدمر وقال نت برايس المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير انتون
بلينكن ابلغ نظيره التركي ملوت جاوش اوغلو
بان عليه ان يرفع سماعه الهاتف ويخبرنا
بما يريد ان تفعله الولايات المتحده
لتقديم مساعده بعد الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب
البلاد على كل حال للمزيد من التفاصيل حول
هذه المكالمه الهاتفيه
وربما الموقف السياسي والاستجابه
الامريكيه لهذا الزل الينا من واشنطن
مناسبه العربيه بير غانم بيير اذا يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده وضعت الخلافات السياسيه
مع انقره
جانبا والان تبدي استعدادها لتقديم اي نوع
ترغب به من المساعدات ماذا يمكن ان تعطينا
من التفاصيل حول هذه النقطه
حاولت عليه اداره الامريكيه خلال الساعات
الماضيه وخصوصا بعد الزلزال بعد ما ضرب
تركيا وسوريا ان تقول انها تتابع الاوضاع
بسرعه مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي اتصل
بنظيره التركي وزير الدفاع على امريكي
اتصل ايضا بناظره التركي وكما ذكرت قبل
قليل وزير الخارجيه واخيرا البيت الابيض
اعلن ايضا ان الرئيس جو بايدن اتصل
بالرئيس التركي بالنسبه المتحده الامريكيه
هذه ماساه انسانيه بالاضافه الى ذلك تركيا
هي حديث استراتيجي وعضو في حلف شمال
الاطلسي وكل البيانات التي صدرت عن
الامريكيين حول هذا الزلزال يتحدث ايضا
على ان تركيا هي حليف استراتيجي وان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد ان تقدم
المساعدات المطلوبه للحكومه التركيه خلال
هذه الماسات نوعيه المساعدات التي ستقدمها
الولايات المتحده اليه تقديم هذه
المساعدات هناك جدول زمني بالفعل لارسال
فرق انقاذ خصوصا بان الفرق الانقاذ على
الارض تسابق الزمن لانتشال العالقين في ظل
يعني انخفاض درجات الحراره والولايات
المتحده لديها خبره واسعه في هذا المجال
هناك فريقين انقاذ وبحث كل واحد منهم ما
حوالي
80 عضو يغادرون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه باتجاه تركيا لمساعده السلطات
التركيه في البحث هو الانقاذ هناك الجزء
الاخر من المساعدات وهو المساعدات
الانسانيه التي تم تكليف وكاله التنميه
الامريكيه بايصالها الى تركيا وهناك كلام
جدي ايضا على ان هذه المساعدات لن تكون
مرتبطه فقط بهذا الحادث هو خلال الايام
والاسابيع القليله المقبله بل بدا
الامريكيون التحدث على مساعدات بعيده
المدى وتصل الى اعاده الاعمار في تركيا
ومساعده تركيا على اعاده اعمار المناطق
المدمره هناك جزء اخر من هذه القضيه وهو
قضيه المساعدات الى سوريا كانت المناخه
نقاش حاد في الولايات المتحده حول هذا
الموضوع وقد اكد الامريكيون انهم لن
يرسلوا المساعدات عن طريق الحكومه السوريه
بل ان ذلك سوف يتم عن طريق المؤسسات
الانسانيه
بالحديث عن موضوع ارسال المساعدات الى
سوريا انه هل تم بالفعل اتخاذ هذا القرار
وتم التنسيق مع المنظمات
الانسانيه الموجوده على الارض لايصالها
وهل يحتاج هذا الامر لموافقات من قبل
النظام السوري للسماح بوصول هذه المساعدات
كان هناك نقاش واضاحات اليوم في الاجازه
الصحفي للمتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه نادي
برايس حول هذه القضيه اولا قال انه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه متمسكه بابقاء
المعابر مفتوحه ونفهم من ذلك المعابر
المفتوحه بين تركيا ومناطق حيث وقعت هذه
الكارثه في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا ثانيا
ليس هناك لائحه
بالمؤسسات الانسانيه التي سوف تتعامل معها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن من
المعروف انها الامريكيين يعطون مساعدات
للمنظمات الدوليه التابعه للامم المتحده
وايضا لديها في بعض الاحيان تعاملات مع
بعض المنظمات الموجوده على الارض وقد
اوصلت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع باقي
الحلفاء والاوروبيين الكثير من المساعدات
الى هذه المناطق خلال الاشهر والسنوات
الماضيه انا اشكرك على كل هذه الاحا
والمعلومات مراسل العربيه بهذا الغنم كنت
معنا من واشنطن
اعود الى ضيفي من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفيا
استاذ اوكتاي اذا تركيا حسب مفهمنا من
مراسل العربيه بئر غانم قد تحتاج في
المستقبل الى مساعدات طويله
الامد في ظل هذا الزلزال الكبير
والتداعيات الاقتصاديه الكبيره التي
ستلحق بتركيا التي تضررت اقتصادها وتراجعت
عملتها برايك هل ستكون تركيا قادره ولو
انه الحديث عن هذا الموضوع ما زال يعني
سابق لاوانه لكن هل ستستطيع التعامل مع
كارثه من هذا النوع
وربما احتواء تداعياتها دون اي مساعده
خارجيه
يعني من المؤكد انه سيكون هناك مساعدات
خارجيه من الحلفاء ومن الدول الصديقه حتى
ان لم تكن هذه المساعدات اعتقد ان تركيا
طبعا هذا تاخذ ضغطا
تقطر على تجاوز هذه المهنه وهذه الصعوبات
وهذه المشاكل يعني كذلك كانت كما قلت
زلزال مرمره في عام 99 مدمره جدا واحدثت
اضرار بالغه على المستوى البشري والمادي
ولكن تركيا تجاوزت يعني تداعيتها خلال
سنوات قليله حسب بعض
يعني
قراته من بعض الخبراء الاقتصاديين ان
الاضرار يقطر الاضرار ما بين 50 الى 100
مليار دولار
اضرار ماديه من هذه من هذا الزلزال ونعم
سيكون هناك اثار سلبيه خلال سنه سنتين او
ثلاث سنوات ولكن الاقتصاد التركي مهما بعض
الصعوبات والمشاكل اعتقد
[موسيقى]
يقطر على تجاوز هذه
المهنه وهذه المشاكل
يعني كذلك بنفس الوقت كما قلت تركيا تمتلك
خبره كبيره في
مثل هذه الحوادث هذه الكوارث صحيح من
الحديث عن موضوع الحوادث خبره التركيه في
اداره الازمات موضوع الاشخاص
الذين تشردوا الان اصبحوا في العراء بسبب
تدمير المباني او بسبب خشيتهم من العوده
الى مساكنهم خشيه حدود زلازل اخرى او هزات
ارتداديه كيف تتعامل الحكومه التركيه معهم
خصوصا ان هؤلاء موجودون في مناطق شديده
البروده وان جهود اسكانهم صعبه للغايه
الان
يعني الامر ليس سهلا حقيقه
كحاله الطقس
وكذلك التضرر الطرق حتى بعض الفرق الانقاذ
عالقه في الطرق بسبب اغلاق الطرق
وهناك مشاكل في الوصول الى مناطق
التي تضررت نتحدث عن مناطق واسعه اكثر من
عشره محافظات التركيه
ولكن بنفس الوقت كما قلت يعني هذه هي هذه
اداره الكوارث كوارث
تمتلك خبره كبيره تم كذلك
استنفار جميع المؤسسات الدوله التركيه
بالاضافه الى مؤسسات
البلديات اطارات المحليات وكذلك الجمعيات
مؤسسات غير حكوميه وما الى ذلك وهناك
مؤسسات
عامه مفتوحه للمتضررين
المدارس
ومؤسسات
حكوميه كذلك تم ارسال الخيام بيوت
متنقله الى المنطقه اعتقد يعني خلال يوم
يومين
يعني
ستكون
الجهوزيه اكبر بكثير يعني
استضافتها او لا الناس في هذه
المؤسسات في هذه البيوت المتنقله او في
الخيم
الشتويه وما الى ذلك
لا تنقص امكانيات بهذا الخصوص ولكن هناك
الصعوبات كما قلت
هذه المساعده هناك
المتضرره وصلت الفكره موضوع مهم جدا لذلك
ستصل مساعدات من الخارج
يتعلق في موضوع الان يعني الاشاعات وخشيه
الناس من حدوث هزات ارتداديه الى اي مدى
نجحت الحكومه التركيه حتى الان في تحديد
المنصات التي يمكن العوده لها من قبل
المواطنين لاستقاء المعلومات الدقيقه حول
كل ما يحدث سواء فيما يتعلق باعداد
المصابين
وحاله
المناطق التي
يتواجدون بها وما اذا كانت معرضه لهزات
ارضيه ام لا
يعني السلطات كما قلت هناك
المسؤولون من هيئه الاغاثه وهي الطواري
والكوارث تقريبا في كل نصف ساعه من في كل
ساعه
يخرج للاعلام ويتحدث ان كان هناك شيء جديد
ويحضر يعني هناك تحذيرات مستمره للمواطنين
من الاجتناب
للاستماع للبعض الشعيات المتداوله في
الرسائل الاعلام وكذلك عدم الاقتراب من
البيوت
يعني
قد تكون
[موسيقى]
تتعرض للتدمير وما الى ذلك هناك يعني ما
اريد ان اقول تحضيرات مستمره للمواطنين
وهناك اعتقد يعني تركيا معتاده طبعا ليس
هذا الحجم ولكن معتاده لمثل هذه
الزلازل كانت في هذه المنطقه في قريبه من
هذه المنطقه زلزال في منطقه اعلاذق زلزال
في منطقه وما الى ذلك يعني
زلزال مرمره في عام 99 كانت نقطه
يعني منعطف جديد في تاريخ تركيا بهذا
الخصوص تم تشريع القوانين وزادت
التحضيرات والتوعيه وما الى ذلك وتحديث
المباني والمونيه التحتيه نعم قد لا تصل
الى المستوى المطلوب هذا الصحيح وهناك لا
توجد مشاكل على مستوى القوانين
والتشريع ولكن المشكله اعتقد في التوعيه
والثقافه الناس وكذلك المراقبه يعني نجد
ان ان لم هناك ما بعني حديثه مدمره هذا
دليل على الخلل ربما في المراقبه ربما في
الفساد الاداري وما الى ذلك ولكن بشكل
مجمل يعني اذا قارنته هذا الزلزال الكبير
بزلزال المرمره اجد ان
يعني اتمنى ان يكون عدد الضحايا اقل
بالتاكيد نتمنى ذلك يعني
لكن سؤال اخير ولو تجبني عليه موضوع
التكافل الاجتماعي في تركيا لاي مدرسه
يساهم في استيعاب هؤلاء المشردين يعني هل
هناك ثقافه استيعاب الاخر هل يمكن ان
يستضيف الاتراك بعضهم البعض في هكذا ظروف
نعم هذا ما يعني الجانب الاهم
حقيقه في المجتمع التركي في مثل هذه
الاحداث يتضامن المجتمع مع
الضحايا
ويظهر المجتمع يعني
تضامنا حقيقيا وهذه الثقافه استطيع ان
اقول ثقافه التركيه حتى تضامن مع جواريا
مثلا عندما يتعرضت الشعب السوري
للمشاكل يعني
تركيا فتحت هدودها وتضامنت اظهرت تضامنا
كبيرا وما زالت يتضمن رغم مرور سنين طويله
يعني هناك نعم يعني نعول على هذا الروح
التضامن للمجتمع التركي لمثل هذه الهاتف
والدوله التركيه تمتلك امكانيات نعم هناك
صعوبات هناك مشاكل وهناك نقص ربما في بعض
الامور ولكن
بسبب هذا التضامن الاجتماعي اعتقد يتم
التغلب لكثير من المشاكل ربما نتحدث عن
الجزئيه التي اثرتها الان في الساعه
القادمه موضوع ما اذا كانت تركيا قادره
الان في ظل هذه الكارثه اذا ما جاز
التعبير التي اصابتها ان تقدم يد المساعده
الى الجاره سوريا التي ايضا تضررت كثيرا
بسبب هذا الزلزال والحصيله يعني بلغت 1440
قتيلا حتى الان وهي مرشحه لارتفاع هذه
التغطيه مستمره
مشاهدينا على قناه العربيه اخر حصيله
لاعداد الضحايا في تركيا اذا بلغت
2379 قتيل واكثر من 14 الف اصابه بحسب
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فيما سجل
تدبير اكثر من
627 مبنى تشهد المستشفيات في تركيا ضغوط
كبيره بسبب كثره اعداد المصابين اما في
سوريا فارتفعت الحصيله كما ذكرنا الى
1440 قتيل ولا احصائيات دقيقه حتى الان
لعدد الاصابات بحسب المصادر الزلزال دمر
مئات المنازل لوفاقم معاناه السوريين في
الوقت الذي عبرت فيه الامم المتحده عن
خشيتها من تسجيل مزيد من الضحايا في سوريا
وتركيا جراء الزلزال المدمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]